as they race through aleppo's wrecked
streets
warplanes circle overheads
this once prosperous city is in pieces
and the people living in the shadows of
an endless conflict
are desperate
when the rescue workers arrive they find
out there are no survivors
but they're used to that now their work
is horrific
they slowly recover the body parts of
the victims killed
in yet another air strike elbow is the
most dangerous city in all over the
world
the situation actually is so dangerous
we
hear bombing all the day we have bombing
a lot of people are killed every day
and we will hear pumping this this is
the bombing the sound
this is this is the sound of bombing
russian introversion change changed the
game and we have a lot of bombing
targeting several defense centers
targeted hospitals darkened schools
targeted markets a russian airstrike
targeted at hospital and today we have
another airstrike another hospital city
in opposition held aleppo hell is a word
the traumatized population uses
frequently
these pictures of what life is like in
the east of the city which is besieged
by government forces
were filmed for sky news over the last
few days
amidst the ruination flickers of
normality
[Music]
not yet snuffed out by the constant din
of war
there are still games in the streets
but the children no longer flinch when
the bombs start to land
playtime for many is spotting and hiding
from the russian warplanes
cutting through the skies above children
adults everyone is desensitized now we
don't feel anything now i
i saw it in my own eyes aleppo there was
some battle
bump there was a huge explosion and a
child hit something like that and he
started to do something like that
as if it is a music for them now
[Music]
they feel that normal life means there
is bomb
normal life means there is a jet fighter
in the sky normal life says that there
is a
airstrike normal life there is no food
normal life there is no water
this is what is happening
aleppo was once syria's economic hub but
now its shops are shuttered
and its buildings are battered
a few supplies have got through the
blockade a delivery of tomatoes and
potatoes from idlib
is quickly and calmly shared out
this is the first fresh food to have
arrived in more than a month
aid workers say the humanitarian
situation is deteriorating rapidly
inside aleppo now the city is only about
35 miles from the turkish border
where much needed supplies are waiting
to be delivered
but the journey is too dangerous it's
why the united nations is now appealing
to all combatants to hold a ceasefire
before it's too late
ten days ago the rebels partially broke
the siege of aleppo
after they captured the district of
ramusa
[Music]
the success though has led to an
intensification of the fighting
as president assad's forces attempt to
reverse the gains
it means more pain for the civilians
trapped inside
alex rossi sky news